cities have a phenomenon called the
urban heat island effect which is
primarily due to the generation of heat
by cars air conditioning buildings
people we know that people in cities are
disproportionately affected by climate
change so I was curious to see how we
can use cities as part of the solutions
to both mitigate and adapt to climate
change I had read an article about how
new paint was being developed that could
absorb some heat and reduce temperatures
of surfaces and I know that endless
graphics and tables don't really move
people I had heard about our new Dean of
the art school Kim Pinder who is an
expert in urban art and I reached out to
her and I said hey is there something
that we could do together to move people
and inform them inspire with them
through ART in cities we decided wow we
should try and build some kind of
relationship some programming together
around Community mural making and this
cooling
paint you know we have a mural that is
on Mill Street in New Haven that was the
final result but I should say it's not
over we're going to build this project
also around training up local artists in
the art of mural making and so then to
actually create a sustainable art
community for so many of the empty walls
that are in New Haven art can pull you
into thinking about an issue that you
may not have wanted to or even thought
you ever would and I think that's the
the storytelling capability of all the
Arts if art or cool murals can inspire
people to have conversations and then
ultimately act on climate change it's a
success
[Music]